mr. quiz what well I've been asking
questions but nobody answers other than
said sell fast you got in a [ __ ] ok
let's let's continue so until now he
said really I didn't tell you anything
new in a sense that I I mean I don't
know how much I told you things that
were new to you but this is all kind of
what if there's a classic understanding
of generalisation downs for convex
problems and mirror descent not that
what I'm gonna tell you in the next few
minutes is so new either but but that
was kind of more to set up the stage of
what you mean in terms of optimization
and we're gonna spend some time talking
also about the problems the search
problems Australia with an
underdetermined problem so in particular
just remind ourselves where we are we
are telling my problems minimizing the
training error and where the number of
parameters dear it's something is gonna
be P is much much bigger than the number
of examples so the problems are under
determined there are typically many
global Optima did have zero error okay
so I mean this doesn't miss asleep
there's you can get through but we are
gonna look at situation we can actually
get 0 and you can get 0 in many ways and
we're gonna optimize it maybe using
stochastic but just think of it if it is
about optimization using some geometry
and we're going to convert to some goal
from a W infinity so this is you can
think of it as the limit of your
optimization procedure so you're gonna
optimize all the way to converges you're
gonna look at the limit of your
immunization procedure in infinite array
that is definitely gonna be a global
optimum awareness which blah blah blah
ok so let's start with the simplest
possible problem just least squares so
we're just optimizing an undetermined
least square problem right so it's a
least square problem with many many more
dimensions of variables and equations
okay so again the there are many
solutions here but the question is if we
optimize the square these d square palm
starting from zero which of these many
solutions will we get to which causes do
cleaning too initialization in
particularly initialize to zero if we
start in zero which isn't even get to
the middle normal solution ok so this is
probably the simplest example of
implicit bias off optimization for an in
terment system this is an understeering
system many global Optima gradient
descent converges to a very specific
reasonable solution in of norm solution
now it's very easy to see why one way to
see why is that we're gonna stay in the
span of the data and the unique solution
that's been buried a day is an effective
an enormous solution but I'm actually
gonna say the exact same thing in a much
more complicated way because we're gonna
see many other proofs that are kinda use
the same basic proof structure so we're
gonna argue it is one we're gonna say
that the they turret stay in the span of
the data well it's been if they spend in
a metaphor that can be characterized
this way in this case is just a flat
manifold and the way to verify that the
solution stay in this manifold is
because at any point in this manifold
the the gradient is tangent to this
manifold which means that if I'm already
in this manifold I mean getting stuff in
the direction of the that's going and
finish most up in the direction of the
gradient then I'm actually gonna stay in
the manifold so at least this works and
for doing the decimal steps in this case
since the manifold is flat it's even
gonna work if I take finite steps I can
work for any step size okay okay
and now so this tells us where the
solution lives now we're optimizing this
optimization problem but I'm claiming
that what we're actually doing is
optimizing this purple translation
problem how can I convince you that you
go to go block off the purple
optimization problem so what we're gonna
do is I'm going to write the K condition
KKT condition of the purple optimization
problem okay so in this case the KKT
conditions we have the primal
feasibility and stationarity can you
know is the dual variable and I want to
emphasize these are not the KKT
condition problems of the problem which
grading descent is operating on okay so
the cake gradients operating on this
optimization problem these are the KKT
conditions of the part of the implicit
problem I'm claiming that you're
actually optimizing and so what I want
to wear
to convince us we actually going to
satisfy these KKT conditions okay so the
first condition primal optimality that's
very primal feasibility is gonna up is
is easy to say because if we actually
reach a global minimum optimization
objective then X W is equal to Y and we
satisfy it is gonna hold your global
minimum okay
so reach of the minima this is going to
hold but also if you look at this
condition what is this the as long as
we're in this manifold any point on this
manifold satisfies the stationarity
condition okay so all along optimization
we always satisfy stationarity which you
go below we also satisfy primal
feasibility hence we satisfy the KKT
conditions of this purple problem and we
know that once we if we run getting cent
and actually converge to a global minima
we will actually be solving this purple
transition problem okay and this is and
this proof thing could we'll see well
depending how much time we see will
might see dr. proof again or at least
I'll mention you can prove things this
way a few more times where we're showing
that by following the doing gradient
saying you are implicitly going to
satisfy KKT conditions for some problem
so so what we actually have to do in
order to figure out was implicit biases
frequently work backwards to see what do
we satisfy when we do optimization
algorithm then ask ourselves Oh what are
these KKT conditions KKT conditions off
okay okay
and as we said in this case sorry where
it's deep no this is a dual variable
okay but okay so I want to satisfy for
some new okay so we're gonna satisfy
with s equals no okay okay
okay now in this case there's something
very special happening just one second
is that since the manifold is flat then
I can take finite steps and I can even
use momentum and all kinds of things
like that this will soon fail because as
soon as this manifold is not gonna be
flat the manifold the graininess in the
center the Nagre be flat in order to
stay on it I have to take in if in
decimal steps because otherwise kind of
a jump off it
Oh fit and I also not allowed to do use
a momentum I know momentum I kind of do
ski jumps and go off the manifold okay
well as long as we're fine we're flat
and everything is fine
okay so in if we change this realization
then this manifold would be different
okay so here I so I have to in order to
say they stay in the manifold they guys
have to say two things one is I that the
gradient is tangent in the manifold
everywhere and that I actually start in
this manifold okay right okay I'm great
so okay so the the so let's see so this
is what we analyzed so far is least
square problems with gradient descent so
let's just stick with still least square
problems okay which really is just you
know you can think of it as convex
learning problems with this chord loss
objective okay and now see we can we
develop this vocabulary or for each
optimization algorithm to ask the
question of where is this optimization
algorithm converge to it so for gradient
descent we converge the minimum
euclidian norm solution what about if
you do mirror descent okay so if you do
me a descent and we started you know the
equivalent of zero which is kind of the
global optimum off site so this is a
good place to start because if your
implicit by your bias is given by
precise size kind of your price you
think up size your prior then well where
you should start is kind of our priori
the minimum size is a good place to
start okay so if you do mirror the since
starting from the middle soluble and
you're gonna converge you're gonna
converge to a global minima but which
Boogaloo minima are gonna converge to
this is sorry minimum side right so they
just minimum the minimum size solution
if you start in a point which is not an
upside what you're going to convert to
is the mid the minimum bregman
divergence to your initial point but I
don't like Brendan divergence so that's
why I started starting here okay and the
way to see this is exactly the same
proof as as we did before but now you
know you you know basically I'm not
going to show the proof but again I mean
you have to you can show that the
iterates Lyons a manifold and if your
cringer second manifold the width
with global optimality then then you get
a KKT conditions for this optimization
problem okay so that means that so this
is what you get from your descent what
about natural gradient descent so
natural gradient descent at least if the
step size goes to zero we know that
natural gradient is the same as Mirror
descent and so again it'll go to the
same thing I mean but here we already
see that we have to start taking the
step size to zero if you do natural
gradient descent with finite step sizes
then I don't know what you're gonna get
to in fact what are you going to get to
depends on your step sizes so here and
here I could take any step size policy
any step size policy that will ensure
convergence okay but now we start seeing
that it's in order to be able to exactly
characterize where we get to it's
important that their step size and fit
testimony small yes as long as you step
size or reasonable Bureau distance so if
you step sit for example if you take
it's easy to derive conditions in your
step sizes here again so if your step
sizes are such than true convergence or
your step sizes are not our first
summable but not summable or something
like that I mean depending on now your
exactly your conditions and oh and this
is what's right if your step size you
have a fixed step size it's less than
the smoothness parameters list in your
converge that's not sound problem your
solution convergence is easy converges
to global off this is a convex
optimization problem okay so converges
to global minima is very easy here to
establish okay okay and in general later
on we'll talk about problems where maybe
it's harder to establish convergence of
global look and mostly we're not gonna
be that's Jason that's not me I mean
that that was the talks yesterday this
morning right we're gonna assume that we
convert Rugel minima and ask which go
minima but again in these cases it's the
converge to global minima is very easy
to establish
okay so here we already see that we
study the step size goes to 0 which
already makes things a bit Messier we
also saw something similar I mean we
didn't see this result yet we just
mentioned it in the introduction that if
you do gradient of the factorization so
right you have the same problem but now
we think of double use and metrics you
just arrange it as a metrics and
optimize another factorization then we
sort of get to the minimum minimum you
you clean minimum you're a nuclear no
solution but now we have to take the
step size to zero it didn't take an
initialization to zero which is a
problem because it's zero as a saddle
point so I can actually initialize at
zero I have to test me close to zero
things started to be a Miss okay but
let's even go back to this maybe as a
good not exactly convict so let's go
back to still convicts things what about
Adam now or at aground we started
talking about either grad we talked
about that a grad at the beginning so
there's a big difference in relation
between at a grad and nuclear in grading
said what happens if I take the least
square problem and now optimize it
without a grant yeah I'm gonna get to
global minima which go over in a mother
I'll get to really know this is a guess
there's a good guess here okay so the
kind of guess that you're supposed to
have which norm or the norm from X okay
okay so not exactly square either grad
is trying to do actually is optimize
respect to L infinity norm so kind of
you guessed should be that you minimize
fill you get to the minimal infinity
norm solution but actually that's true
that turns out to be not true it's only
true in very very special cases even and
that's even if you take the step size to
zero you know do here it's not exactly
clear what it means that a substance 0
but it turns out that this is actually
very delicate and you can't actually
characterize in the you know the the the
solution you're gonna get to depends
very much on the parameters of anagram
so even for this very simple problem
already for either grad we can't exactly
characterize the device let's look at
something even simpler which is to
position with respect to some norm so
again we're gonna take at least square
and optimize it with CPS and respect to
some norm what are you what solution are
you gonna get to any guesses right well
it to me the dual norm right it be the
dorm norm on W right so we're talking
we're talking about the solution we're
gonna characterized in terms of W we get
to so maybe a good guess as we get to
the minimum norm solution we expect the
same no no we're taking steepest descent
so that would have been a good guess
that was also Argos but the problem is
that's wrong okay so it's hard to
characterize what you get her in fact in
some sense you cannot characterize what
you get to but it's definitely not the
minimum norm solution respect to that
norm even if you take the step size to
zero so even if
you to gradient flow if you do this in
the the the continuous time limit you're
not gonna actually get them in enormous
solution so when you saw this first were
a bit surprised but then we realized we
actually we knew this before because if
you look at court according to said
coordinates and a steep is a certain
respect to L 1 norm and we know that for
coordinate descent it's kind of related
to L 1 minimization but it's not exactly
our one minimization so think of the
less so so looking at the least square
problem with l1 regularizer is exactly
the also in we know that Lars
what's Lars Lars is essentially
coordinate descent the coordinates
ethnically square problem the specific
coordinates ending at coordinate centers
ill-defined and we know that Lars is
related to the low so but it's not equal
to the lessor it's not the same thing I
mean it's only the same thing under you
know some very special conditions i've
ever hold ok
and so even for this problem we already
knew that we you know in retrospect that
you're not going to get to the minimum
solution in fact it's the case that for
any norm you're not gonna get an
explicit
any non quadratic norm you're not gonna
get to the minimum norm solution okay
and so what we see here is even for
least square problems which i talked was
in kind of the simplest to analyze it's
actually difficult to exactly
characterize the implicit bias no
because mirror descent is not the same
as steepest descent so if you do so if
you do if you do infinitesimal case so
if your LP norm okay for LP norm if you
do infinitesimal step size okay so if
you do help you know in the front a
small step size then that's natural
that's the same as let me think about it
no it's not the same no no it's not the
same because remember that the the
divergence of the LP norm is not the
help the LP norm so if you look at the
rent and so natural gradient descent
with respect to the LP norm to the
Hessian of the LP norm is different and
steep is a single spec the LP norm
okay and nobody does natural grain in
some respect nobody the nobody that I
know except for Sarang when she did
these experiments actually does steepest
ascent with respect to the Hessian of
sorry natural gradient
respect the Hessian of the LP norm okay
yes okay so that's an excellent question
we'll talk about it a bit later and the
short answer is I don't know and I'm
very interested
so in particular I mean this is a
question to the audience maybe there's
an answer here I mean I am can you get
generation guarantees for early stopping
of flowers in terms of the l1 norm so we
tried we looked at that
Sariah saying yes I said we look at that
we're not we're an inconclusive okay so
so that's an excellent question so if
you do really if you do follow the
regularization path of the if you do
let's also follow the organization path
of the l1 or into explicit organization
we know what to get good generalization
guarantees and what happens if you do
Lars which is your steepest descent
respected l1 norm with early stopping
can you get realization guarantees that
with respect to L 1 or anybody know the
answer I don't but I we looked and I
thought that their answer was known we
couldn't find it
yeah you can't look at a book so we'll
get to later the other person will
understand why you can without a boost
okay yeah it's it's it's different okay
okay so step says go to zero what I
really mean formally what I mean by step
two is going to zero is this continuous
time limit so the solution of the OD
that we had before a gradient flow or
the flow version of these things okay
then then it's much more complicated
so yeah line searches I don't know how
to analyze we'll talk about it later
we'll talk about a little bit later in
the book three slides okay okay so this
is 4 squared loss so we saw that Square
dose is actually kind of annoying to
characterize fortunately the squared
loss is not the loss we usually use for
training deep networks the loss we
usually use is again the cross entropy
loss which really is just the logistic
loss okay or the motive cursive just
across and so what happens for the
logistic loss so that's something the
same problem we had before so now I can
talk about a neural net right it's this
very nice simple neural net with a
single unit also known as logistic
regression
hey so I saw just linear logistic
regression
and again what's gonna happen here so
that I'm interested in the over
determined serene underdetermined case
so I'm trimmin case there are many
dimensions in particular there many ways
of separating the data so many ways of
the many ways separated data and what we
ask is what happens when you actually do
gradient descent of the logistic costs
okay so what what happens when you do
grinding synergistic loss where were
like converge to whereas whereas there's
a question clear so I'm taking this
objective I'm gonna start somewhere and
I'm do gradient descent on the
subjective respect to W where is W gonna
converge to if the problem is linear
separable what what okay it's not going
to converge it's gonna diverge okay
because the infimum of the loss here is
zero and this is an important point the
envelope the loss is zero but it's not
attainable okay I can drive the loss of
zero by taking W to infinity but I'm
never actually gonna reach zero okay so
I can do that in the direction of any
any linear separator if you have an a
linear separator and I taking W in that
direction W that defines this in your
separate it's orthogonal direction it's
gonna find a gloss and if I take W to
infinity here I'm gonna drive the loss
to zero okay so W is actually gonna
diverge and this is a very important
point because people talk about the norm
that you get the norm of the weights you
get by training you take a neural net
and train it and get zero error and then
you talk about the norm of the weights
the it convergence what does that mean
that there's no norm of the weights and
convergence right the weights are gonna
go to infinity
okay the norm you get that the only
thing they're turbines which normally
get is how far you know how long you
spend optimizing it so so what this is
the cross entropy loss
this is the cross entropy dose the cross
entropy you inspected softmax model well
just the cross entropy respect the
software magma suffer but soft max model
is exactly the multi-class logistic
regression okay so this is a unit is the
Congressional means the only single
output so this is a cross entropy loss
to a soft max model where one class is
given by the l code and the other is
given by the negative out okay this is
exactly across this is the same thing
would happen for there the cross entropy
loss which is exactly motocross logistic
regression okay okay so we're going to
diverge to infinity but it doesn't
matter with the virtual finicky about is
only what this separator is so rather
than asking what is W going to converge
to which it's not it's going to diverge
we're asking what is it which direction
is it going to diverge store in other
words which the nearest separator is
going to converge to okay so I can get
this zero error in many different
directions I need a direction I actually
separate the data okay but which is the
direction I get if I act in all of these
directions are legitimate directions in
terms of you know different directions
are gonna try and get the infimum this
doesn't have not them but get an infimum
of the problem okay which direction do I
get where I actually is gradient descent
okay the question clear though okay so
you what yes max margin right so what
you get is exactly a hard margin SVM
solution max margin inspector you're
cleaning them okay so that's and now we
can actually characterize it very how
much how many doing it time when I'm
supposed to finish another hour from now
okay so just trying to decide where to
do the proof right okay so and what we
can get here is we're gonna get to the
max margin but you can even say what we
get much more finely what we get is we
converge to the max margin more
specifically as syntactically the
solution is going to look like this it's
going to be look like the max margin
solution times log T plus some error
term which is gonna stay bounded so in
particular as T goes to infinity this
term is dominated and we're going to
converge to the max margin solution okay
and this is a much stronger result
inside results we saw for the l2 case in
particular this holds for any
initialization in with even finite step
size any any finite step size okay and
it holds and what's special here it's
holds not only for the logistic loss
what's important here is the loss as a
tight exponential tale right so
so just the clothes when when the
predictions go to infinity when Z goes
to infinity this behaves essentially as
e to the negative Z so any loss that
behaves as the limit is e to the
negative Z so in particular many of the
results I'm going to show you are I'm
gonna prove them for the X plus e to the
negative Z and I'm going to think about
in terms of logistic loss because for
separable problems the behavior the
limit is there is only the turn by the
tail of this loss which looks like e to
the negative Z so in terms of separable
data logistic loss and the X plus or are
the same at the limit okay so maybe I'll
very quickly go through this proof just
to get the flavor of things so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna assume we
convert to some Direction W infinity I
mean you can show that you can prove
that you converge to it but we're gonna
here assume that that you convert to
some limit so that means that the
solution is given some 1080s
emphatically by some increasing function
GT times W infinity plus some Rho where
Rho is smaller than GT right because W
infinity is is the limit so now we just
have to figure out what is this W
infinity okay so since the problem is
separable then we're gonna drive the
lost eventually everything is gonna be
we're gonna separate all the data points
and so far enough from from zero we
definitely have the W infinity times X I
set all the labels here for one for
convenience it's definitely gonna be
positive mean so let's look at how the
gradient of the loss looks like so the
gradient of the last memory we're
thinking of the X plus and surf logistic
loss so great if the X plus is just the
X plus itself so have e to the negative
prediction times their data points okay
so now the thing is that since I have
something that looks like this that as
sgt in the skills all things increases i
guess i go further and further away then
only the the only the points that are
closest to the margin that have the
smallest values of w infinity x i are
going to dominate this this exponent now
this sum because they're their values
are going to be infinitely larger than
anything else okay so that means
that the gradient is spend only by the
points that have minimal value of W
times X I and I'm gonna keep adding them
back to X so that means that my iterates
are also going to be dominated only by
those points so that means that the
gradient so that means that my iterator
spend by by what are these points are
exactly the support vectors they're
spent by the points that are kind of
have our have the minimum margin value
that are on the margin okay and now
again if I I can use that and I'm gonna
be very quick here but I can use that in
order to construct the cake and D
conditions for the hard margin SPM
solution and so argue that it gets into
my X margin SVM solution okay
so what does that tell us so I'm gonna
maybe I'll take a questions later
because okay so the fact that we get the
hard marching scream solution here is
maybe not so surprising I mean there was
somebody's guess here who's also our
kind of first guess I mean if you ask a
random person off the street they'll
probably tell you that is their first
guess depending what street you uh you
live on I'm sure that's true for some
streets okay but but you can already see
much more fine things than that so one
question we can ask is well it's going
to the max margin but how fast is the
action are we getting there how fast are
we were maximizing margin by how fast in
the solution is it the answer is
exceedingly slow if the math then max if
we ask how quickly we get to the max
margin we're getting there is 1 over log
T ok so if you look at the the muck the
surf the barge and the far so both if
you look at if how quickly we're getting
close to the max margin solution or
we're asking how is our the margin
behaving relative to the max margin
they're both going down as 1 over log T
contrasted with the loss the loss is
going down much much faster the loss is
going down as 1 over T ok and this is
already interesting because it means
that if we really care if there were if
we're thinking we're doing we're
minimizing logistic loss but really the
reason we're minimizing they're just
across or maybe not the reason but
implicitly what's going on is we're
maximizing the margin there in order to
get a good margin we have to drive that
logistic loss extremely extremely low so
that already explains why maybe when you
train your neural net and your your
training loss goes down from 10 to the
negative 4 to 10 to negative 5 okay and
while the training loss goes down from
10 negative 4 to the negative 5 then
your your test they are improves
improves maybe
go drops from the Oh 7% to 5%
why did your training loss draw your
testosterone from 7% to 5% it did not go
down by 2% because you're fit to the
data improved by 10 to the negative 5
right that's not like your already
figure data perfectly I mean that's not
the reason it improved why you can say
maybe it improve is because you're
finding you're improving the margin your
agarose Asian term improved but the
margin goes down so much slower than
training loss that this suggests why
it's important to drive the training
loss so ridiculously continue optimizing
or digging the training loss for so long
after it's already like barely changing
ok and you can see this ok I'm going to
scoop you can see this empirically ok ok
so now let's look at this so we saw that
for 4 squared loss it was kind of
difficult to get a precise
characterization of the of the implicit
bias for some problems let's know as the
exact same question but for for logistic
or logistic flight losses so we say that
we have you know one linear unit so it's
linear logistic regression you get the
hard margin SVM solution in if you have
multiple if you have a multi class
problems if multi-class logistic
regression you're getting get you some
multi-class SVM solution but now if we
ask what happens to do steepest ascent
so again whether the exact same problems
you just solve a logistic regression
problem we're only going to change
optimization algorithm ok so now instead
of solving it with grading descent we're
gonna do it solve it would still be the
same with respect to sub norm so before
if we stop if we solved the least square
regression with cbsn respect to some
normed and I don't know what we got but
we solve logistic regression is
speculative norm we get exactly what
we'd expect which is the max margin
solution with respect to that norm so
the solution that actually gets an
output of margin of 1 and minimizes that
norm ok so we have a much tighter
connection between the optimization
geometry when using stiffness descent
and the
an implicit bias and again we can it's
particularly insightful to look at the
special case of coordinate descent
so for coordinate descent which is to be
the same respect to L 1 norm what this
tells us is it will converge to the max
L 1 margin and actually the way I'm
presenting things here is not his not
historically that reflective of
historical development because
historically development actually
started with corian descent and in fact
the the the technique that I showed you
for for establishing the implicit
Viceroy L 2 actually was the right from
the techniques developed for studying
the accordance with respect to L 1 why
are people standing coordinate same with
respect to L 1 because adaboost is
exactly coordinate descent and x+ it's
exactly coordinate 7x plus so starts to
be the same respect to L 1 on the X plus
and that was known already by you know
from the work I mentioned before by
Peter and co-authors that that tended to
get to minimize the L 1 norm and so we
can understand translation in terms of L
1 norm but now there's some subtleties
here because what adaboost exactly is is
coordinate descent coordinates and X
plus with exact line search and that
actually does not converge to the max L
1 to the max L 1 margin solution does
not actually minimized L 1 norm now was
pointed out by Cynthia senior burden Rob
Shapiro and English thank you
so they showed that actually even though
it was tends to minimize Dale 1 Evan
doesn't exactly and then Matus showed
that you it's true that with exact line
search you don't exactly get them the
neck the max L 1 margin but by slightly
fixing at a boost you can actually get
exactly max L 1 margin you can do that
even Jewish by slightly shrinking the
step sizes or what we saw here is we're
just taking a fixed step size so if you
do add a boost with a fixed step size
you will exactly get to the max L 1
margin and the proof technically showed
here is exactly just matters
proof technique modified to general norm
is that a fair statement or okay so and
now we can also see other problems
before we had a problem with which is
this matrix completion metric
characterization problem I am we're
gonna I'm actually not sure we're gonna
see the proof for it so again for the
metric stricter ization problem where
before we kind of got minimum you can
ignore him but only kind of because we
couldn't prove it on leaving special
cases and only if you had started
fantastically close to zero and if in
testimo step size and was amiss in with
the x bus we can do the same thing we
can ask what is you know we have a
problem with the metrics argument we're
writing this vectorization which is
something we'll just across i think of
it as like one bit 1 bit metrics
completion or something like that like
condition for crucification you just
have up/down measurements for each entry
and now in a much more robust where you
actually get to the max
trace nor margin so minimize the trace
time subject to a good margin of 1 and
in some sense the reason it's much
easier to analyze the these just a
closer generally these exponentially
decaying losses as opposed to the
squared losses there's nothing special
here about the squared loss to logistic
itself the big difference here is
whether the loss looks like this and has
a unique finite minimum or whether it's
monotonically decaying to infinity in
the reason is that if it the losses
monotonically decaying to infinity that
that means as we saw the solution is
gonna go to infinity so you're gonna end
up infinitely far away from the origin
if you're gonna end up instantly forward
from the origin doesn't matter which
finite point you started i mean any
point you start with from the
perspective where you end up is at the
origin okay
and so the semantics here are much
easier and much cleaner also the step
size don't matter as long as you have a
figure so this is my exact line search
is a problem because then the step sizes
might be very like might actually
increase as you go further away from the
origin but as long as you're taking a
fixed step size then eventually when you
know when you finish your optimization
your step size is going to look
minuscule compared to our and where you
are so the some tactics are much more
convenient in this case than in this
case and here in this case you're going
to end up in a finite solution and all
these finite fluctuations the beginning
can affect what you're doing very lot
okay okay okay so so far what we talked
about is we didn't talk about learning
in the last few slides all we talked
about is just a pure algorithmic
question if I'm gonna use some algorithm
namely
you know say steep in the Senate respect
to some norm or gradient descent or
something like that
what is gonna be the output of my
algorithm okay this is a determine a
deterministic empirical algorithm what
is going to be the output how can we
relate that to learning how can get
learning guarantees from that well I
mean once we understand what the
algorithm is doing so once we understand
that our optimization algorithm thing of
a is optimization algorithm actually
returns the minimum size solution with
respect to some society like the l1 l2
they'll want something like that you can
think of this maybe it's a margin loss
then at least in a realizable case you
can get your realization guarantees in
terms of the complexity of the sub level
set subside so in particular you can say
that you can bound the the population
loss of the algorithm in terms the
Rademacher complexity of these sub level
sets or Suk's you know generally would
look something like this with some
complexity measure here that depends on
your structure okay so that means at
least in a realizable case we get a we
understand the generalization what's
going on here now the question is what's
going on in an onion realizable case
okay so not a realizable case and this
is maybe goes back to what Vitaly asked
before
I mean learning still makes sense right
so then maybe think of the realizable
cases not realizable case instead of
thinking of can you get to your error I
think the better questions do you want
to get to your air so the realizable
case you want to compete with some
hypothesis W star that has your error
and also small sign in the 90 realizable
case type off this is I want to compete
with is a simple hypothesis and have
small plight but it doesn't necessarily
have zero or just want to compete with
some hypothesis that has small error
okay so I want to get a preview firmly I
wanna learn some W that has air that's
less than the loss of W star plus some
complexity measure depends on W star
okay how can I get that so I can get
that by explicit organization how can I
get that something like this also with
implicit organization so now they're
they're kind of two basic options here
sorry several basic options one is to
say oh I want to compete with this W
star that has small error but still I'm
gonna do that by completely minimizing
the training here okay so that's
interpolation or named Peter talked
about it this yesterday okay in in for
that understanding in terms of
optimization I supplied Peter everything
he needs I told them what my solution
finds I find a zero error solution that
minimizes some sight and now I can move
past this on to Peter and not just Peter
has to solve interpolation learning
problem the problem is that we still
don't understand interpolation of any
problem and we don't understand when we
can exactly do interpolation learning
working in that but that's you know if
what we're doing is depletion learning
that would be satisfying and actually
for deep learning it seems that we are
actually doing interpolation learning
and so maybe that is a satisfying answer
here so in terms of optimization I just
have to understand this zero error case
hey you seem concerned okay okay but
let's still think of what can we do if
we do want to do don't want to do
interpolation learning so if you don't
want to do interpolation or anyone we
probably want to do is early stopping
okay so what we probably want to do is
not find the zero solution so how can we
do optimization without finding zero
solution we're still in optimize the
empirical air with some optimization
procedure wedges we're going to stop
before we have zero error okay how can
we analyze that
so the two ways to analyze that either I
can exactly tell try to characterize
what is the output you get so the where
Outsiders can relate the optimization
path the solution you get if you do
early stopping at different points with
the regularization cap the solutions you
get if you do explicit realization and
that would be in bigger realization
interpretation or for early stopping so
I can tell you are you doing the early
stopping that's exactly corresponds to
this type of organization okay then
we're gonna see an example of that I
should say that another approach we can
say is say well maybe when I'm doing
with early stopping it doesn't actually
correspond exactly to regularizing but
it just generalizes the same so this is
kind of related to what we saw at the
beginning we saw that yesterday the--
doesn't actually solve a rigorous DRM
problem it just generalizes the same so
maybe if I do early stopping what I mean
by really stopping this of doing
stochastic gradient said I'm actually
gonna batch gradient descent but I'm
gonna stop the batch gradient descent
before it actually gets your error so
again I mean gonna I maybe I'm gonna get
a solution that looks like this but
maybe then get a solution is very
different in it but just generalize it
as well okay okay so let's let's look at
some examples so first let's see how we
can relate the optimization path and
realization path
as far as I know there's only one
example we can really do that and that's
for least square problems with gradient
descent okay so we then again look at
this least square problem so the
optimization path is just defined by
these batch gradient descent iterations
okay and we're gonna relate it to the
realization path which is defined by by
the actual minimizer not nope no
algorithm going on here I'm just looking
at the minimizer of my empirical loss
plus different values of realization
different values of lambda so for lambda
equals 0 this is just the actual risk
minimize range for lambda goes to and
when it undergoes to infinity this goes
to 0 and I'm gonna is equal to infinity
this is just 0 okay and the limit of
these two things so if I take as I said
if I take lambda 2 0 I don't have any
relation here is the same as I'd get if
T goes to infinity here then I'm gonna
get actually the minimum norm sorry
yes you're a loss solution but not just
the zero loss solution both cases we
know they're gonna get actually the norm
solution okay here you're gonna get the
minimum or solution because you're still
gonna use as long as you have you still
kind of some preference to minimize the
norm and we saw that for grading descent
we're also gonna get the minimum
solution so the end point of the
realization craft an optimization path
are the same point can we also say that
they're the same all along the way so
ideally what we want to show something
like this that WT is equal to W hat
lambda with some relationship between TN
lab can we do that okay so sir if we can
or not we but actually nay in there
Cesco but in order to do that we cannot
do that for a fixed e rather what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do a really
stopping when you're gonna sue
randomized early stopping so we're gonna
choose our stopping time at random okay
we're going to choose a stopping time
and random following some geometric
distribution so what Gregory with Greg
and Lorenzo Gregory in there and Lorenzo
showed is this if you stop occurring in
a random time based on geometric
distribution then the the early stopping
the they're really stopping it or an
expectation here and now is not over the
data or anything expectations only with
respect to stopping time is exactly
equal up to some scaling that very
quickly goes to 1
- they're agarose Asian past where i can
tell you exactly what if you stopped
after expected time of t it corresponds
to lambda which is roughly 1 over T
decreasing 1 over Etta T so the step
size also matters here okay so in other
words then at least with randomize
stopping the regularization path exact
does exactly correspond to the
optimisation the optimisation that does
exactly correspond to the realization
guys so during the stopping is just the
same as adding your realization term so
this is for randomized stopping you can
also ask what happens if I done the
randomize stopping if I do if I just
stop at some point
and okay I'm not I mean the answer is
that you can also say what happens there
at least a few average they direct with
the certain averaging which basically
amounts to you know doing truncating
this expectation at some point and then
you get an additional correction and
what you get what you get at that point
is that you don't get exactly
optimization but what you get is that
after with you know with some averaging
of minarets after T iterations and again
this is gonna be very close to 1 very
quickly just ignore this term what you
get is is WT lambda which is not exactly
a point in optimization path but rather
what happens if you optimize the
regularizer objective using T steps of
gradient descent
ok so doing T steps of grading send
without regulation corresponds to doing
T steps of gradient descent with
regularization ok that make sense ok ok
so the point is that we we kind of
understand this but we only understand
this for least square problems with
gradient ascent I'd really love to
understand this actually more generally
in particular from one as far as I know
we don't understand this even for maybe
the second most interesting thing which
is least square problems with coordinate
descent so what happens or even so you
know if you look at stop lars early or
even for boosting even 4x plus with the
coordinate descent so 4x plus I mean you
mentioned early stopping I don't know
how to relate an early stopping
iterative how to get your inhalation
guarantees for early stopping iterative
adaboost before you're in the realizable
case like before you actually have when
you're when you're training error is
well above zero
to the to the performance of l1
memorized solution but I know how to do
it after the constraint deadlocked okay
so I'll be if she showed me that later
I'd be happy to see her okay so okay so
so he said we this is the an approach it
relates the directly relates the
organization path optimization bath
another way to deal with early stopping
I mean is just get generalization
guarantees after early stopping and
there has been some work on that both
for boosting and for and for Colonel
Ridge regression in some sense you can
interpret some results on for a greedy
selection also is results enough for
accordion descent for least square
problems but I have to say that I I mean
I all these results interpret things a
bit differently and and I don't think we
have kind of a nice unified theory of of
what's going on here
but anyway maybe this is not so
important because if we're building
interpolation learning anyway then all
this is sort of less relevant and we
should be thinking about what happens
when you do drive the training error to
zero anyway okay so that's we're gonna
what we're going to focus on and so so
far we only talked about shallow convex
problem and the remaining like what five
minutes or something when we have 35
minutes remaining 35 minutes we're
finding on a trout drove to deep deep
problems and see what's going on
so the first deep problem we're gonna
look at is my favorite deep learning
problem
of course metrics vectorization so
metrics provision is is actually a deep
learning problem because it's a
corresponds to two layer network with
linear transfer okay so don't laugh this
is or the deep non convex problem that
exhibits many of the situations that
happens in deep learning and as the
distinct advantage that we actually have
an understanding of what's going on
there okay
okay so you already saw this before
we're going to look at these this least
square problem and linear measurements
of our metrics we're going to parameters
a matrix is a factorization a full
dimensional factorization is a gradient
Santonio and we can ask what happens and
actually here I'm writing is U times V
what I'm gonna analyze is actually the
symmetric case a few times u but it's
really just the the non symmetric case
is actually a special case of the
symmetric case because of a non
symmetric problem I can always encode it
on the off diagonal blocks of symmetric
matrix so the symmetric problem actually
encompasses also the non symmetric
problem so I'm going to limit myself
only the symmetric problem and as I
already mentioned before then roughly
what's going on here is that the that
the that at least if we start close
enough to zero and two except in small
enough step size then the solution we
get is going to converge to a middle
nuclear or solution so to make this a
bit more formal then again we're going
to look move to the continuous limit
here so the continuous time limit and
now grading the sense of gradients and
we're going to talk about gradient flow
so granting flow on U which is given in
this form and I can expand this out I'm
going to go through this a bit quick
because actually I'm curious how many
just so to decide which of the three
topics I have I'm gonna skip how many
people have already seen this I really
reassured differently how many people
have not seen this and would like to see
it okay okay so they compromise and kind
of do it with double speed and half
detail because I want to get to the
tangent kernel stuff as well okay so so
the thing is these are the granion MX
and U and we can also talk about the
induced dynamics and W so again this is
something we'll see later on remember
that I mean use the factorization W is
the resulting matrix and so
the dynamics I can ask what are the
granny nameks and you imply on w these
are not the gradient dynamics in w
nevertheless they're still well-defined
dynamics and w okay in particular here
i'm writing and just plugging in you but
since u transpose U is just u I can just
substitute W here
and I can write the dynamics and W
purely in terms of W so I can forget
about you and just say that doing
grading so the gradient descent on you
corresponds you know the gradient flow
and you corresponds to some other than a
mix on W then you can see this just as
instead of thinking about Anna so I'm
doing grading sent and a different
parameter ization I'm just optimizing W
with respect to a different geometry
okay I'm doing I'm following a different
dynamics and W a different notion of
local geometry and W okay and I can then
ask I mean this is gonna find if this
finds to go up and I get it so it's non
convex and somebody asked me before how
do I know I find the goal of them I
don't know but if it finds it often I've
actually I do know because you can prove
here that under some conditions going to
find good water but that's not for today
if you find it above de which go blocked
why are you going to go to okay
and now it depends on an initialization
so we're gonna for any initial W naught
we can talk about what is the limit of
this of these dynamics and the formal
conjecture here I'm not sure if you
still should call the conjecture is that
for any full rank
W tilde if we initialize to 0 times W
tilde initially is to offer time
stablished in time take the this scale
of initialization to zero then the limit
of these dynamics becomes the minimum
nuclear norm solution okay so this is a
conjecture and what can we do here well
we can prove it formally for the special
case where the measurements commute
right and so that's not very I mean it
doesn't give you metrics completion of
metrics completion measurements
definitely do not commute it does give
you maybe reconstructing the metrics
from from certain linear observations in
my commute maybe the most interesting
case here which is still already
non-trivial is if you take the
measurements only on the diagonal so
then they definitely commute and then
what this problem boils down to isn't
even a simple
we'll return to again later which is
just a linear prediction problem so now
everything that's a diagonal so this is
just a vector problem okay so the
measurement Mexican is measurements a
system matrix we have aw minus y so
these squared problems but we're
representing W in the strange form of WI
squared so each in surf parameterizing
the the coordinates of our predictor as
W or parameterizing them is UI square
and what and so we know that if you do
Karen gradients N and W we're gonna get
to the minimum euclidian our solution we
don't coordinate what this tells us if
you do grading sendin you we're gonna
get to the minimal one or solution
that's already kind of interesting we
see that we get a different different
bias for the same optimization problem
just by optimizing a different
parameters okay for general
non-cumulative measurements the best we
can do is wave our hands really wildly
in the air and do some empirical
observations and say that it looks like
we're also surf minimize the nuclear
norm or maybe not what okay but let's
actually you know something I'm gonna
skip the proof of this I'm gonna say
that the proof just precedes similar to
the proof we saw before by looking at
the dynamics saying you stay on the
manifold and constructing a KKT
conditions and let me just skip oh this
actually because you wanna actually yeah
I'm gonna there's several progresses in
this is I'm gonna mention okay okay let
me just say that for the this may be
advertised this for the non-cumulative
case so why is the commuted case
important versus an uncompetitive case
so in the in the commutative case okay
okay maybe I'll sort of I'm not gonna
fully give the proof but just say that
in the cumulative case the important
thing is in commutative case we can
characterize the mana for the solution
stays on so the solution stays on a
manifold that looks like this
it looks like WT times some exponential
of you know a star SD for some s T times
this ur SD is actually the integral of
the rid of the residual so you can think
of the residuals as steering us from
this manifold but even if I forget what
the visitor jewels are I'm still gonna
stay on this manifold so this is a non
flat manifold that it's so so manifold
and now I can say that if
stay on this manifold and satisfy global
optimality and initialization goes to
zero which another way to think about is
they go infinitely far away the origin
this manifold then I'm actually going to
satisfy the condition for the minimum
solution I'm not gonna go through the
details but the in the the the the point
is that again the only thing we used
here is that we stay on this manifold so
actually get something that's
independent on the steering the steering
is are these residuals the residuals
tell me where on this manifold I'm going
to be okay so think of it again grading
these standard grading Center least
squares so and then the solution is then
the solution spanned by the data and
wherever you are the residuals tell you
how much are you going to add each
different data vector to your solution
so tell you how are you going to steer
on this manifold spend by the data okay
in the the argument here is completely
independent in the steering we only
needed to say that we stay on this
manifold the problem with
non-commutative measurements is that for
noncommutative measurements then
actually we can be anywhere in our space
then now the order in which we actually
take you know add up our measurements we
can you know that once things done
commute and by adding things in
different orders you can get anywhere so
we no longer have a manifold to state
and another way to say this is the
solution is given by this time ordered
exponential okay so if the measurements
commute and I can replace these this
product of expectations with expectation
of the Sun and the solution is just in a
specific manifold but one what but but
once the measurements don't commute then
now I cannot do that and the order of
them is actually is important and I have
to have some other argument about how
the solution of this time or the
exponential behaves in particular I
definitely do be to do depend on the
on the steering here so it's a very
crazy steering I can get anywhere in my
space the thing is if I actually solve
this problem in fact you you do the what
I get for metrics completion problem
metric circulation problem I don't
actually have crazy steering I have some
sensible steering and at least the limit
I don't get so many completely crazy I
still get on something that behaves
roughly as if these measurements
commuted and I don't know how to make
this formal nor whether it's true or not
okay but let's so I went through this in
a bit maybe less detailed and I would
have hoped but you can find this you
know something you can online you can
find talks of this online if you want so
I can get the version you can actually
understand it just summarize so this is
the conjecture raised in 2017 we still
don't have a resolution of it as you
said we have a rigorous proof when the
matrices commute tengu who is was here
before thank you here
no thank you okay so a ten year and the
student have proof in another special
case which is when the measurements are
are IP and the metrics is approximate is
low rank or maybe approximately lori i
think you're just exactly the rank but
again then it's a bit difficult to say
whether you're going through mini
nuclear-armed solution or just the
minimum rank solution or just solving
the problem you're reconstructing
because these are conditions under which
you can actually exactly we couldn't the
the the mineral nutrient solution is
exactly the planted solution our claim
is even if you're in a situation where
you're statistically cannot fit the data
you're still going to them in a nuclear
solution again that's back to the
experiments we can run experiments which
an immunity or clearing solution is not
the planted solution or even there's no
planted solution we still go through
nuclear solution but again we we don't
know if this is true and then there's
some there have been at least two proof
attempts that I'm aware of that did not
work out not by us in several attempts
at found in counter examples it seems
kind of difficult to also find counter
examples here I I don't actually know at
this point I'm not sure I don't have a
good sense of whether this is true or
not so the problem is that it's very
difficult to have an empirical counter
example because the claim is what
happened is
this happens only when the steps list
goes to zero that's not so bad but also
an initialization goes to zero and the
problems the initialization goes to zero
it becomes extremely difficult to
actually optimize and we have some
evidence I'll suggest soon that suggests
that the initialization should go to
zero exponentially exponential in the
error you're willing to tolerate and so
if you get a numerical counter example
it only has small deviation from the
unica norm which is what the american
example has been so far it's not very
confused not very convincing okay but
let's continue so what we saw so far is
one deep puddle but let's look to models
which maybe you would start looking may
be more familiar like actual deep
networks and you know what laugh at me
that I'm doing neural nets so we said if
I train the single a neural net with a
single unit no linear regression so in
logistic regression that what I converge
to is the heart margin SVM solution and
now we can ask well what happens if I
actually train it'll still talk about
linear neural network so linear
activations but have multiple layers and
you know a bunch of units and the answer
is actually that's very boring because
what you get is again you just converge
no matter how many layers we have how
deep you are and how wide you are if you
if all the activations are linear and
you have a single output and you train
with the grading descent you'll still
get to the heart margin SVM solution no
we have to just stop a second to
understand what I mean by that so what
is a linear neural network a linear
neural network is just an over
parameterization of a linear predictor
okay so what I'm telling you now is not
what the weights of the network would
converge to but those weights and
network actually represent some linear
predictor and I'm telling you what is
the linear predictor that they actually
represent and they actually parameterize
what is it going to to go to which is
really what you behave what you care
about how is the function computed by
the network on a behavior okay so the
function computed by the network is
going to converge exactly the hard march
in stream solution so that's pretty
boring okay but what happens if instead
of talking about a fully connected
Network we look at it still linear and
network with an involution on the
network so what's the linear convolution
Network a bunch of layer each layer is a
full-width convolution so each unit area
of as many units and each layers as
inputs with the same weights but shifted
by one okay so we have all the different
shifts
rotations actually of the previous layer
in old activations here are still linear
so this still computes a linear
predictor and it's pretty easy to see
that you can get any implement any
linear predictor this way so the model
class here is still the model class of
all in your predictors but and now we
can ask also the same question of what
happens if I train this network with
granny descent which linear predictor
I'm going to go to okay so I'm
definitely going to go to a linear
predictor that separates the data but
but in the undetermined case there are
many linear predictors that separate the
data which of them am I going to
converge to any guesses so this is okay
so when you're going to converge to at
least if you have one convolutional
layer is the max l1 margin in the
frequency domain so in other words
you're going to be implicitly minimizing
the l1 norm of the Fourier transform of
your linear transformation okay so
you're gonna get sparsity in the
frequency domain now this is with one
layer if you have multiple layers again
so for fully connected layers it didn't
matter how many layers we have but we
have convolutional layers if we have
multiple layers and what we converge to
is we're implicitly minimizing the
bridge penalty the LP bridge penalty in
the frequency domain for p equal to
depth over 2 to over depths okay so if
you have you know ten layers we're
getting the l 0.2 regularization in the
frequency domain again just to
appreciate what's going on here we're
getting very rich inductive bias very
rich bias we're biasing ourselves to
sousou-san's are sparse in a frequency
domains alright so this is what you'd
get if you'd use a fully connected
Network this is what you get with the
depth to convolutional Network this is
where the five conversion network okay
so you're getting to what I'm plotting
here is the linear predictor so you get
get sparse in frequency domain and we
did not do that by neat by changing the
model class nor by imposing this
explicitly this is a byproduct of the
fact that we're doing graining sent on a
specific parametrization which imposes
some specific geometry on our search I
mean okay so this is exactly a type of
phenomenon we want to understand now you
might ask well why am I getting white
here does the depth not matter and
suddenly we're talking about conclusions
that does matter or how do I get this so
really the secret here I feel like when
I when I show this I feel like this
looks like so this looks like magic
to reveal the my magic trick to you or
it's actually serious magic trick to you
so actually what a convolutional network
actually is doing you can think of it is
it's it's working
it's as if that each layer can apply
Fourier transform in an inverse Fourier
transform that cancel each other so you
just apply a Fourier transform in the
top and in the bottom and so really what
you're doing is you're just having a
diagonal Network on the free a transform
so what's the diagonal network it's a
network it looks like this it's a deep
network but but with very boring
connections that the that the the weight
metrics of each layer is a diagonal
matrix and if you use the diagonal
Network not a convolution list with just
a straight-up diagonal Network no
convolution or nothing then what you get
here is the Brid the same bridge penalty
but now on the signal domain not in the
frequency domain so the difference
between this and this is whether it's
diagonal or complete indifference in
these two convolutional non convolution
is whether you're working in a frequency
domain or in the signal domain okay okay
but again in both cases here by
increasing the depth then without
actually changing the model class were
changing our implicit realization okay
so what we saw here is actually we
talked in beginning about when you talk
about convex models we talked about the
the geometry of the optimization itself
so we talked about gradient descent
works with one geometry and steepest
descent works with a different geometry
and mirror descent works could a
different geometry and now I mean I
would argue that we're still talking
about geometry but the geometry is
different the G on the differences in
geometry doesn't come from the name of
the optimization algorithm I'm just
using gradient sent from all of these
the the geometry comes from the
different characterizations so the
examples we're seeing now is we're
seeing examples how looking doing
gradient descent on different parameters
ations of all functions and by changing
my parameter ization I'm actually
changing my I'm not changing my model
class the set of functions I'm working
with I'm only changing this the geometry
over that function class so here in our
metrics completion problem our function
classes mattresses and we're working on
all matrices and we're looking at it
we're working on a particular
factorization of all and particular
parameters ation of all matrices which
imposes a certain geometry for the local
search over matrices and that's what
leads us to the million new cleaner for
the the
linear convolutional networks and we're
working over all functions this class
all functions those linear functions or
entire universe is just linear functions
by design by using a specific
architecture we're not changing our
function class all we're doing is
changing the parameterization through
that the geometry induced by that
parameterization okay and I would argue
that that's also what happens with none
with neural nets with nonlinear
activations you're essentially
representing all function right that's
what we said at the beginning okay but
the way you're what's important in
architecture is not what functions you
can represent to represent all functions
what's important and what is the permit
translation of all the set of all
functions so it can also give you an
example of where you can see the
importance of this parameterization for
actually a neural net with nonlinear
activation so in particular if we look
at infinite with rel and networks okay
so look at whether networks with one
input unit is that still a well-defined
class it's also pretty rich I'm I can
model now univariate functions I can
model any univariate function okay so my
model class is just all univariate
functions but you can now again ask what
is this geometry of the universe
functions that is imposed by the
specific parameter ization of all
univariate functions right there are
many other ways of parameterizing all
univariate functions infinite
organization ways in particular I can
ask what happens now now I can actually
exactly tell you what happens if we do
grading descent can tell you what
happens in the organism with weight
decay but it's still it's a very simple
inductive bias it's a very simple
organization in the parameter space and
they can ask you what is this impose in
the function space so it turns out that
what does impose an ingrate in the
function space so when you're training
if you're training a infinite with rel
Anette work with weight with weight
decay on the weights this corresponds to
learning a function by implicitly
minimizing the integral if the absolute
value of the second derivative so some
some kind of second-order total
variation of the function so this is
very rich and kind of natural inductive
bias on the class of functions I mean if
you're trying to learn the univariate
function when regularize it's some way
this would be a very sensible regulation
to choose but
here it's coming again implicitly by the
choice of parameterization so what were
what we're seeing here when they talk
all the time about geometry really it
has two components what I really care
about is the geometry of in in function
space so we're talking about all
functions the question is just what is
this geometry overall functions the
geometry under which we're searching and
because of that the JumpShip inductive
bias the geometry of the sublevel sets
that will lead to generalization okay
and we're searching in parameter space
to know if to consider on one hand the
geometry in function space and that's
given may be implicitly by optimization
algorithm you do gradient descent it
gives you one thing to do steep isn't to
get something else okay so you have some
geometry in function space this geometry
might be fairly simple but now what I
care about is what is the induced
geometry in function space and what we
saw in the last examples has a
relatively simple geometry in in
parameter space can actually induce very
rich and complex geometry and inductive
bias in function space okay so by in in
the role under this interpretation the
role of the architecture the role of the
model is not in specifying the model
class but rather in specifying this
parameter is Asian and so specifying the
geometry in this model class which is
anyway the set of all functions okay
okay so let me a fifteen more minutes
okay so so in particular so this so
let's look at it a bit more and in
particular I want to relate this to what
I'm gonna try to do it in many 15
minutes is also relating this a bit to
the kernel view of the J's Jason still
here actually I'm gonna need you I'm
gonna need you soon because I don't
actually completely know what I'm
talking about here so the how this
relates to the tangent kernel view of
things so let's recall what we did and
formalize it a bit more so we said that
we have the model what's our model a
model I think the model is a mapping
from parameters to functions right so a
model may be all functions are linear
functions something like that so you can
think of it as also split so you have a
model class the model class is the range
of F but then our model class is gonna
be everything it's gonna be very boring
okay and in particular we're gonna write
it as f w X is the output on input X
with parameters W so this is gonna be
the function we're gonna work on you
talk about the loss of some parameters W
in and write to the model maps from here
to here and we're and in four linear
models particulars are going to be
linear functions and so we're gonna use
or we can really talk about the model is
mapping some W to be a better W the
linear predictor parent rise by by the
weights W okay that's if we're going to
talk about your models in though the
questions can we can only give a general
theory that relates the that that that
relates okay sorry okay so so in
particularly the type of models we're
gonna talk about our D homogeneous
models and you should think of the so
what's the deal marching this model so a
deal modulus model is a model where if
you multiply the parameters by some see
the model gets multiplied by C to the
power of D and you should roughly think
of deere's your dips okay so one
homogeneous models are just models
linear models not linear in X I don't
care about Daniel in X all our my all my
examples are gonna be linear in X or
almost all of them but they're models
that are linear in W so these are very
boring models either these are the
shallow mental models we know we
understand them pretty well okay
examples of two emerges models are for
example matrix factorization and two
layer neural network so both of these
are tool to homogeneous in general if I
have a deal layer new linear network or
a deal a Arella network I have a deal
homogeneous model so you can roughly
think of the DS as the depth of your
model okay and we can ask the question
can we analyze have a general theory for
D emergence ones and the answer is sort
of so if we at least consider gradient
descent oh sorry maybe I let me just go
back and tell you what the question I'm
gonna answer is so what we're trying to
understand is in all sorry think I
missed an important sentence before in
all the example in all these examples
that we saw here
all the examples that we saw here then
what's really going on here is that the
geometry in parameter space is very
simple just to clean in geometry and the
geometry that we're getting its light in
that okay sorry I think I lost something
in the geometry we're getting here is
very complex so now you can ask whether
all this implicit implicit bias business
really just boils down to having you
graininess and imposing Euclidean
geometry here and really I shouldn't
have given the entire first half of this
talk because I just have implicit job as
the Euclidean geometry in mailto space
and it's all just about the mapping to
function space okay and so we actually
have the result that kind of suggested
in some sense that's kind of the case
but well pretty good so what we can say
is if we consider a deal modulus model
and so in every deal modulus model with
the X plus and we're doing very going
grading Center in the X bus for a deal
modulus model then in fact under some
conditions what we are going to converge
to is exactly the max l2 margin solution
on over those parameters so we're going
to be implicitly minimizing convergent
direction to a solution it implicitly
minimizes the l2 norm in in parameter
space okay subjects is now a good margin
of one okay so in a sense that says that
yes that the implicit bias is given by
just Euclidian geometry in the in the
parameter space in the rich inductive
bias we see in function space is just
maybe a mapping of that so that suggests
that what we get in now what we care
about release function space is the
implicit bias in function space is given
by minimizing this implicit regulation
what is this implicit regulator
it's just the minimum you Euclidian norm
cost of representing H using our model
right so just the cost you know if I'm
having this parameter ization every
function would have a different cost of
representing it where the cost of the
functions is nucleating R min in
parameter space so this is just moving
from this parameter space to function
space the problem is this is not so
clear so first of all this can this
theorem has
a bunch of conditions that I'm not sure
they're satisfied actually so we assume
the predictor of convergence in
direction and we have to have some other
things to convergence direction some
constrained coalification I mean it's
probably you can wave many of these but
maybe that's one concern a bigger issue
here is that note that all these
problems are non convex optimization
problems in what I'm telling you is that
you're going to converge not to a global
minimum here because I can tell you
that's non convex optimization problem
no this is generally non convex because
F is non convex but rather to a
first-order stationary point in
parameter space the problem is that
being in a first-order stationary point
in parameter space does not mean that
you're in the first story you're also in
the induced function is also a first or
and stationary point with respect to the
problem of minimizing the industry
eliezer okay and so then it's because of
that if for all the examples we showed
in particularly like the confidence and
all of that morally this is what's going
on but actually you have to prove
specifically that you actually get to I
first started a stationary point if this
in this regularizer okay and it's none I
actually yes
so D doesn't play for this statement D
doesn't play a role well D equals 1 is
trivial okay so only we do need to you
have to be a modulus but doesn't matter
for tips what determines is the the it
of course has a role in determining our
okay okay what yeah so our R here is a
function of the of the model and roughly
speaking if you're in depth D you'd get
something that corresponds to a 2 over
the over d norm very roughly okay just a
second I wonder I see that I'm already
in that ok let me just finish this so so
so we see in fact that in many of the
examples the rich inductive bias we we
saw where we could completely explain
just by this view of having Euclidian
norm in the function space and just in
terms of what an induces and as are you
cleaning our imperative space in one
induces in function space and we have
this generic result that it that
suggests its draw so more generally but
actually I think that there's much more
going on here first of all this generic
result has all these conditions that
it's a I it's hidden they might not
really always hold and in transitioning
from this from first order stationary
points into promises its problematic but
more than that this is only for deal
margins problems and it's you know when
you move to non-imaginary to you
definitely we know that you get things
are much much richer and even for
emergence problems for squared loss it
seems that this for example doesn't work
so there's a very recent work that's
gonna be an archive I was told in a few
days by Sanjeev Arora and students that
showed that for the same kind of their
deepening particularly implies for these
deep diagonal networks that we had that
we saw that we are well beginning the L
with X plus we're getting this bridge
penalty then with the squared loss you
still get l1 implicit that one
organization regardless of the depth
which means you're starting you get very
different things what you're getting is
not given by Euclidean or more gross
ation here and actually this is not
gonna be coming soon because I think I'm
not gonna have time so right now this is
to me one of the questions now I'm
interested in really understanding
what's going on here is all this story
about implicit bias just about you
cleaning geometry here and this
inductive bias which is still very
interesting enriched or are the things
that are much more much more interesting
going on we're an inductive bias really
is very different like if you do very
different in here and again we have lots
of examples in which the examples I
showed you it is the same but we have
lots of examples which we don't fully
understand which we see things are
different maybe I will actually have
time to show you one of these okay maybe
I will try ten minutes for now five six
wait my watch this is okay so okay so
one thing that's been bothering us
lately is all this tangent kernel stuff
so what I mean by all this tangent
kernel stuff so as Jason said then in a
certain regime then gradient descent on
our model behaves just as if we're
working on the linear model and this
suggests that gradient descent just
converges so we're just it's a it's a
linear problem and linear problem we
know exactly what gradient descent
converges to it continues to the minimum
clear norm solution or in particular but
remember this is not you cleaning our in
parameter space this is now just
including on for a linear problem and
this suggests that all the inductive
bias
boils down to is just minimum norm
solution are max margin solution with
respect to some norm in some in some
linear space so some kernel norm respect
to some current namely the tangent
current initialization from my
perspective this is a very disappointing
answer because this suggests that the
only thing you can do with neural Nets
is the same thing you can do with
kernels or in other words if you're
learning we're seeing if fencing your
own that's using all your GPUs then
that's equivalent to just doing SVM with
some kernel or kernel retrogression with
some current and kernel logistic
regression maybe okay and we know that
kernels you know many things you cannot
do with curls in particular you would
hope that there are things you can do in
neural nets you cannot do it currents or
at least you know neural nets
empirically have been much more
successful in with kernels so some
people maybe would answer it yes
actually everything we do with curls we
just have to come up with the right
cradle but to me it seems that the the
powerful neural Nets really goes beyond
just kernels so what's going on here so
one way so one thing we've been thinking
off this is the kernel is you really the
important regime in an important
distinction here is so there are many
parameters that control whether any
kernel machine were not in one parameter
I want to focus now is the scale of
initialization so in particular we'll
focus some deal modulus models and we're
consider granuflo for the homogeneous
models where we changed what the only
thing we're going to change is the scale
of the initialization so we initialize
to alpha times W not for different
alphas and and we can ask when would
this behave like the gradient flow
dynamics on the on the kernel and at
least four squared loss cheese out and
back we should recently showed that the
width here is not important even even
with finite width as long as the
initialization goes to infinity okay if
where is it if the channelization goes
to infinity then you will always be in
the kernel regime you'll behave exactly
like a kernel so this suggests it to be
in the kernel regime you have to be
initialization has to go to infinity now
and so when in particular initialization
goes to infinity all you'll be doing
implicitly is minimizing some norm in
some are some are KHS norm for for
kernel it's the tangent curl now the
important thing is to contrast it with
all with all of our results all of our
results with the squared loss where is
when initialization goes to zero so this
suggests that there's an interesting
transition here between the colonel
regime what happens when opposed to
infinity in the truly deeper richer gym
which goes when alpha goes to zero
because we saw them alpha goes to zero
we get
inductive biases we get sorry we get
implicit biases of the optimization that
look nothing like a kernel organization
so he good we look we get things like
nuclear norm or bridge penalty or
sparsity which are things that cannot be
represented using a kernel no kernel can
represent them so they're definitely not
the tangent kernel okay so can we
understand this more specifically and
okay maybe you consider this as an
advertisement because I'm not going to
be able to go over the details but to
answer that question we considered a
very very simple to emergence models you
can think of as a depth to model or you
know diagonal network of depth to so
this is in particular just repairmen
translation of linear regression model
with squared loss where we we
parameterize the coefficients is w+
squared minus w minus squared okay so
this kind of similar to squared
parameterization before the reason i you
have your w + + w - is i can get both
positive negative parameters so I really
I can say king at any linear predictor
here and also maybe more importantly so
it can initialize at 0 what does it mean
initialize it 0 I can't initialize W at
0 because that's a saddle point
so initially is W as a scaling of the
Irwin's vector so you can visualize all
the parameters to alpha but that means
that the prediction of the
initialization is 0 me and now what's
going on here so we know that this alpha
goes to infinity I'm gonna be at the
kernel regime and the tangent kernel
here is easy to calculate the tangent
kernel is just given by it's four times
its tangent in the standard inner
product realm which means that if I ask
what is the limit of grain inflow as
alpha goes to infinity the answer is
it's just the minimal to an enormous
solution yep but we also know what
happens when alpha goes to zero when
alpha goes to zero I said before that we
converge to ism in real one arm solution
so we see that that just by changing
this realization were in two very
different places minimum l 2-norm
solution and win well one arm solution
now the interesting thing here is we can
actually characterize exactly what
happens for any Alpha so for any scale
initialization alpha we exactly go to
the minimum Q alpha solutions we are
explicit regular Iser here in this Q
alpha I wrote here exactly what it is
it's the hyper entropy it's called
sometimes rigor Eliezer I mean the blind
is a we can write it explicitly and I
can show you what it is it's just this
is the the its minimizing this sum over
all the coordinates of the corner
divided by alpha squared of a function Q
that looks like this
so what's important about this function
is around zero this is quadratic so an
alpha goes to infinity I'm only
interested in the behavior around zero
and I'm essentially going doing l2
realization when alpha goes to zero I'm
only interested in the behavior away
from zero where I'm sensually linear and
I get l1 or grows ation okay but it can
actually characterize exactly what
happens everywhere in between in
particular I can look at the interest
and AMEX here in X T what you know what
is then what are dynamics I get I can
write it turns out they can write the
dynamics in beta in this form so let's
see what's going on here if alpha is
zero then this is just better times the
gradient these are just multiple weight
updates so you get exactly I mean I know
that's going to be l1 when alpha goes to
infinity then this term is constant and
I just get gradient descent dynamics
gradient flow dynamics but I can see
exactly how a transition between those
two regimes and in particular if I think
of how this relates to learning so
imagine you're solving a sparse
regression problem so if you're solving
sparse regression problems or solving a
problem in like very high dimensions and
a thousand dimensions with a sparsity of
five and about 100 observations so I can
solve this problem okay I I can solve
this problem it so to solve this problem
I have to do a one rigger ization okay
and now I can ask what happens if I
solve this problem by by training my my
neural net with different
initializations so if my initialization
is close to zero I will actually be able
to solve this problem I get a small
generalization error because what I'm
doing is essentially minimizing the l1
norm okay
once I increase my my alpha I'm gonna be
essentially doing l2 and be minimizing
the all-tournament I'm not gonna be able
to solve my problem so in particular
we're doing want to optimize here so I
won my alpha I want to be over here
because I want to solve my problem but
the problem is over here I'm starting in
a saddle point this is very difficult to
optimize so in terms of statistically I
want to be with alpha as smallest
the smaller the alpha I get better
generalization but optimization wise I
don't actually want to have alpha it's
super small okay because then it's gonna
take me forever to escape the initial
saddle point so I actually want to use
an alpha which is as large as they can
but still allows good generalization and
the thing is that that alpha will depend
so I always want to be kind of not in
this deep regime but just at them on the
edge of it I just want to be you know
exactly in this phase transition so for
this reason either gets very interesting
to understand exactly its transition in
the kernel regime in the deep regime
okay in particular I can ask the
following question how what happens when
they have more and more data the thing
is that if I have more and more data
eventually I'll be able to learn even
without organization right once they
have more than a thousand data points
that can learn you know without any
realization at all okay if I increase so
if my my if I'm really data starved I
really have to have alpha to be
miniscule me but as I increase my number
of data points I can afford being
learning with a larger alpha so what
we're showing here is I said that since
we said that we always want to be on the
edge of this regime we can ask the
question of how how small do we have to
initialize in order to get recovery as a
function of the number of sample points
and this is the graph we get this is the
informational limit and to recover
information limit alpha has to be
miniscule is to be exponentially small
but once we even have a bit more points
than that we still cannot recover with
l2 norm but we can actually use a very
moderate value of alpha okay okay I'm
not gonna have time to show this because
sub is gonna kill me but let me just say
that I can I can we can also ask
questions what's going on here just just
can we describe in terms of extra
causation so is all this just thing
equivalent to minimizing including norm
- initialization and the answer is they
can also tell you exactly what happens
if you just minimize the Okinawan
initialization and what happens it's
completely different because you again
get an explicit rigor eliezer but this
explicit regularizer this is the
solution some quartic it's a much nicer
explicit rigor eliezer it's in
particularly tells you break as opposed
to transcendental and so the behavior
here is very is qualit of lis different
between doing the implicit organization
and just doing minimum euclidian or in
parameter space if anybody understood
that you should get a price
okay let me uh yeah what cheating okay
okay so I can say that you can see they
all do some phenomenal symmetric on the
metrics characterization problems you
can also these see this transition where
they think Jason also alluded to in
particular okay I'm not gonna go to
Jason okay
later lost elf you anyway okay thank you
[Applause]